Freunde herzlich willkommen zu diesem
Video den ersten Video aus dem neuen
Büro bzw noch nicht so richtig weil hier
drin laufen gerade die Umbauarbeiten wir
essen aber heute einen Tag wie in
Frankreich und das Frühstück ihr könnt
euch denken französische Backwaren
unglaublich lecker aber was kommt dann
noch alles so und wie lecker werden
diese Backwaren wir gucken erstmal rein
was drin abgeht weil hier vorne
entstehen nämlich meine neue Küche und
die wird viel zu krass ich habe dabei
ganz ganz ganz große Hilfe bekommen von
Tobi kreativ Tobi auf Youtube da gibt es
quasi alles was Sie im Büro passiert ist
im Detail zu sehen Dave hat ja auch ein
bisschen was gezeigt aber da vorne ist
er der gute Mann Tobi sag mal Hallo
nee leider nicht okay sehr gut weil ich
glaube das was ich da mal probiert habe
war besser als in Paris du kannst
vielen Dank dass sie wird Betonoptik und
es wird ganz ganz krank wir fahren jetzt
zum Bäcker und holen Frühstück
und ich freue mich wirklich dass wir
dieses Video heute drehen weil das müsst
ihr mal gesehen haben
französischer Bäcker auf der Dürener
Straße hier in Köln Lindenthal und es
ist wie ich gesagt habe ich habe die
krassesten paar Schokolade ich war schon
paar mal in Paris habe ich hier gegessen
[Musik]
so Leute das ist der real deal es ist
teuer also für Backwaren vergleichsweise
aber es ist sowas von seinem Geldwert 25
€ hat das gekostet sechs paar Schokolade
zwei eine Tarte für Eric dann noch mal
lernen also wir sind Steaks auf jeden
Fall aber ich glaube ich glaube die
werden alle nicht klar kommen der Tobi
wird gar nicht mehr klar kommen der will
nur noch bei uns auf Baustelle arbeiten
hier Kaffeemaschine ist natürlich auch
wieder mit dabei im neuen Büro Tobi ich
mache jetzt einen Kaffee Ole das heißt
Hälfte Kaffee Hälfte Milch bzw Milch das
ist die Grundregel der hat natürlich
jetzt nur Cappuccino Tassen
normalerweise noch ein bisschen größer
aber ich werde probieren den klassisches
französisches Frühstück zu bieten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so Tobi Kaffee olé in die linke Hand
gehört ein paar Schokolade ich sag dir
ehrlich lass ich darauf ein es schmeckt
so gut also groß danke dir herzlichen
herzlichen herzlichen Dank dass Du uns
hier so viel hilft dass du also ohne
dich wäre mir wirklich aufgeschmissen
gewesen tobi ist so ein lieber Kerl guck
unbedingt auf seinem Kanal vorbei und
jetzt lass Dir schmecken
siehst du auch den Eiffelturm den
Eiffelturm ja auf jeden Fall ja
und jetzt will ich dass du das probierst
guck mal wie viele verschiedene Lagen
das ist ja bei einem klassischen
Croissant Teig hat man ja so viele
verschiedene Lagen und rein
sind knusprig von außen und innen extrem
weich und fluffig boah schmeckt extrem
gut die Schokolade ist auch richtig geil
ne wirklich wenn das nicht so ungesund
wäre jetzt glaube ich jeden Tag
frühstücken dann nur Butter Schokolade
hier die kenne ich als Kind hat immer
mal wieder so ein Mensch darf man kommt
sie auch in den Kaffee ich mache es
jetzt einfach vor wir haben noch paar
herzhafte Sachen zum Probieren sieht
auch ultra geile diese dann Pizzen
richtig gut einfach so ein richtiges
Frühstück wenn man sich gut gehen lassen
will nichts für jeden Tag habe ich von
Tosen habe es auf jeden Fall verstanden
sagen wir frühstücken jetzt mal und dann
schauen wir was zum Mittag geht so Zeit
fürs Mittagessen ich habe was besonderes
rausgesucht gallett das sind quasi
herzhafte Crêpes und Tobi die gönnen wir
uns jetzt oder
[Musik]
ich mag das Café hier richtig gerne ich
war ja auch schon ein paar mal weil es
halt sehr persönlich eingerichtet dass
er eventuell wir haben hier voll die
süßen Notizen also voll viele Gäste
schreiben hier eine Kleinigkeit auf
hinterlassen hast und man kann einfach
während man hier wartet voll die
Geschichten erleben gerade eben war
jetzt z.B ein Zettel drin da hat ein
paar sein 26-jähriges Hochzeitsjubiläum
hier gefeiert und Max irgendwie echt
gerne weißt Du persönlich ist voll klein
aber richtig cool
[Musik]
ui ui Tobi was sagst du dazu sieht doch
richtig schön aus hätte richtig lecker
aus mit dem Treffen Obst wir haben
Trauben rote grüne Blaubeeren Walnuss
Schafskäse der auch noch mal so schön
angedreht ist man hat das auch schon die
ganze Zeit gerochen das raucht schon die
ganze Zeit so lecker und das hier ist
eben die Besonderheit dass das hier ein
buchweizenkrepp ist deshalb heißt das
ganze auch geil lecker jetzt ist glaube
ich einfach auch herzhaft so immer lass
uns probieren bisschen Honig ist noch
dabei das ist ja auch so die klassische
Kombination so Käse Honig noch nie so
angerichtet gesehen wie so eine Tasche
[Musik]
ich habe echt das Gefühl wenn man das
ist manchmal was Ungesundes oder dieses
Buch Warzen das schmeckt super gesund
aber trotzdem passt das perfekt rein
wenn mit dem Walnüssen der Kombination
den Käse ist richtig gut
der süße Honig passt natürlich perfekt
zum Käse Käse richtig schön kräftig
super lecker Eric du musst probieren was
du sagst weil ich finde es richtig gut
und das ist was ganz außergewöhnliches
Licht lecker ne ich finde die
Kombination süß auch gut und Käse und
dann mit dem Honig übel
weil passt deine ganze Zunge beansprucht
wird so viele verschiedene Geschmäcker
haben ist auch ein leichtes Mittagessen
richtig Spaß der ganze Prozess also
macht echt Kock zusammen zu arbeiten
gute Versorgung
Essen Trinken alles klar mit mir
arbeitet dann muss man sich keine Sorgen
ums Essen machen
[Musik]
die Galette hat sehr gut geschmeckt aber
es wird Zeit für eine echte Besonderheit
ein echtes Highlight der französischen
Küche das Nationalgericht der
französischen Küche Coq au vin kennt ihr
vielleicht Kokowääh der Film und das ist
alles was wir brauchen ein maishühnchen
Champignons Speck Kräuter Charlotten
Zwiebeln Knoblauch Butter Wein ganz
wichtig ein wenig konjunktivenöl Punkt
aber das soll sehr sehr gut schmecken
ich bin sehr gespannt darauf und wir
fangen an indem wir das Hähnchen
zerteilen Champignons schneiden Zwiebeln
schneiden und alles vorbereiten
[Musik]
das erste Mal Hähnchen zerlegt ich bin
sehr zufrieden ich finde es sieht ganz
gut aus das werden wir mal als erstes
nicht in die Pfanne gehen müssen sondern
all das was wir hier haben
darauf dann den Speck die sind relativ
klein deshalb lasse ich sie jetzt nicht
mehr groß aus sondern gebe dazu im
ganzen Charlotten wird es Zwiebeln und
die Pilze der Knoblauch braucht noch
kurz ich muss wirklich sagen man kriegt
nicht so viel mit von der französischen
Küche hier habe ich das Gefühl ohne Til
Schweiger und das ist wahrscheinlich
eher mein Problem habe ich hätte ich
niemals von Kokowääh gehört so nie und
ich bin gespannt ob es Sinn macht dass
es so wenig bekannt ist oder ob es
lecker ist aber von den Zutaten her ist
das so geil kann mir eigentlich nur
vorstellen dass es lecker wird
vielleicht ist es ja auch nur wegen
unserem Standort so dass wir so wenig
davon mitbekommen
ganz anders ihr könnt ja mal die
Kommentare schreiben ob ihr ein bisschen
mehr vom französischer Küche bei euch
mitbekommt das Geheimnis der
französischen Küche ist
toll Litauen also ich kann kein
Französisch aber das heißt ganz viel
Butter und ganz viel Zeit braucht man
für französische Küche
[Musik]
so damit die Hähnchenteile schöner
anbraten weitest du ja noch ein bisschen
aus und gebe darüber etwas Mehl und Salz
wie schön es aussieht oder wunderschön
wenn das ganze so schön aussieht
angeröstet ist nehmen wir uns eine
Schüssel in die wir das alles befördern
und jetzt braten wir das Hähnchen auf
der Haut an und das lassen wir jetzt von
allen Seiten schön goldbraun anbraten
insgesamt ca 15 Minuten
und jetzt dürfen wir eine Flasche Cognac
öffnen und davon gehen wir so etwa 3
Esslöffel jetzt drüber
und dann ihr könnt euch schon denken
passiert die Marie
der Slam das Ganze ab und sobald das
erledigt ist gehen wir darüber einen
halben Liter Rotwein daher kommt auch
der Name Kokowääh Hühnchen mit Wein ist
unser Knoblauch ins Spiel der kommt
jetzt daran genauso wie Kräuter Thymian
Rosmarin Lorbeer die mir auch dazu und
kann mir keiner sagen dass das hier
jetzt nicht krass aussieht
und noch ein Schlückchen Geflügelfond
macht einfach mal noch intensiver so wie
es jetzt ist kochen wir das ganze 30
Minuten mit Deckel ist das normal
bei so einem Hipster Koch Portal also
max heißt der Kanal 30 Minuten sind
vergangen boah wenn ihr also wirklich
wenn man Geruch über Youtube übertragen
könnte dann würdet ihr verstehen das
hier ist unglaublich wie der Rotwein und
der Thymian vor allem ineinander greifen
und wie das riecht ist einfach krank und
jetzt diese ölige angebratene Masse dazu
mit dem Speck
also wirklich unfassbar simples Gericht
eigentlich also wirklich schon fast dumm
simpel one Pot einmal gucken dass alles
halbwegs gut benetzt ist ich habe auch
Highlight von heute ganz klar egal wie
gut die Bäckerei war egal wie gut die
galett war oder an die Bäckerei kommt
wirklich wenig dran das muss krank
schmecken also vom Geruch und von dem
wie es wirkt ist schon ganz große Klasse
aber die Bäckerei Alter okay Deckel
drauf
während hier drüben der Rotwein aufkocht
Flambieren wir einfach die Haut noch mal
ein bisschen weil das ist ja quasi nur
in Wasser gekocht und wird dadurch nicht
so wirklich knusprig natürlich immer
besser wenn man noch eine knusprige Haut
dabei hat ist dann machen wir das ganze
so wunderschön aus es sieht auch schön
aus ja guckt euch das mal an wenn ihr
die Bläschen euch anschaut die Soße ist
auf jeden Fall jetzt schon ein gutes
bisschen eingekocht Burberry toll wir
müssen sie jetzt montieren wir nehmen
jetzt kleine Butterstückchen diese
französische Butter geben jetzt nach und
nach in unsere Soße und rühren Sie ein
wichtig dass dabei keine Hitze mehr da
ist die Butter einzurühren und die Soße
noch sämiger zu machen
[Musik]
zwei Stunden Arbeit das ist das
Endergebnis es sieht relativ hübsch aus
ich ist aber auch so auf jeden Fall so
ein Gericht das schwer anzurichten ist
ich bin gespannt wie das Fleisch ist wie
alles zusammen kommt wie die Soße ist
und warum das das französische
Nationalgericht es wir schneiden das mal
in der Mitte an
[Musik]
Hähnchenbrust man sieht auf jeden Fall
diese besondere Farbe die das
maishähnchen hat safe geht direkt mal in
die Soße rein und probiere einfach
also krank diese Soße ist heftig wie
beschreibt man es am besten also das
Hähnchen könnte bisschen saftiger sein
die Soße macht das aber super gut weg
also dadurch dass du wirklich diese
vollmundige intensive kräftige
Rotweinsoße hast die wirklich heftig
schmeckt das könnte die beste Soße sein
die ich bisher gemacht habe selbst ultra
viele Zwiebeln drin fünf Zwiebeln vier
Schalotten
[Musik]
Ernst krank wir müssen einfach ein
bisschen Reis gemacht der nimmt
natürlich die Soße auch noch mal richtig
gut auf oh ja der schneidet sich schon
butterzart
ist ein ganz eigener Geschmack kannst du
mich nicht vergleichen die Soße ist 10
von 10 super intensiv die
Hähnchenschenkel sind super zart
französische Küche sehr underrated weil
bisher wusste man eigentlich dass alles
geil ist ne italienische Küche so weiß
wie das ganz krank aber das ist wirklich
underrated also man denkt auch sei nur
so ultra edle Küche aber wir hatten ja
auch heute sein die Galette und so ist
ja auch einfaches Essen das und ich weiß
das sage ich auch kann ich nur jedem
empfehlen nachzumachen weil es wirklich
was ganz eigenes ist und ganz eigenes
Gericht ein eigenes Geschmacksbild ich
würde sagen Leute danke fürs zuschauen
wir sehen uns beim nächsten Video wieder
und schreibt in die Kommentare welches
Land ich als nächstes austesten soll
Frankreich war wirklich sehr stabil